بصوته المميز واسلوبه الفريد استطاع
المحاور مفيد فوزي وهكذا كان يحب ان يلقب
استطاع ان يضع بصمته في عالم الاعلام على
مدار اجيال يرحل عن عالمنا بعض صراع مع
المرض نشوف كل حوار له طعم لانه الحوار
نظره
فابتسامه
حاور الكاتب الصحفي الكبير والاعلامي مفيد
فوزي ابرز مشاهير الوطن العربي من نجوم
وكتاب وسياسيين ابرزهم نجيب محفوظ احسان
عبد القدوس عبد الحليم حافظ الذي كانت
تربطه به صداقه والموسيقار محمد عبد
الوهاب وغيرهما من نجوم الفن
معارك ضد
حزب اعداء النجاح
لكنهم ابدا ابدا لم يسقطوه ظل قائما يحب
وطنه
صحفي في مجله صباح الخير قبل ان ينطلق في
عالم الاذاعه والتلفزيون له برامج عديده
في الراديو والتلفزيون المصري وايضا قنوات
الخاصه اشهرها برنامج حديث المدينه حيث
كان ينقل نبض الشارع هي عن قضايا الساعه
وكانت له مدرسته الخاصه في الحديث مع
ضيوفه للوصول الى المعلومات يعني دائما
ارى وجيها ودائما عنده وجهه نظر اا مختلفه
في اي موضوع
وانسان وطيب ولطيف وكريم تزوج من الاذاعيه
امال العمده والده ابنته الوحيده حنان
التي تعمل ايضا في الصحافه ومنذ ما يقرب
من شهر دخل فوزي المستشفى حيث تدهورت
حالته اثر اجراء جراحه تركيب دعامه في
القنوات المراريه وظل في العنايه المركزه
حتى وفاته المنيه تاركا اكبر ارشيف اعلامي
لمشاهير مصر والعرب منذ خمسينات القرن
الماضي وحتى اليوم سمر باشات لصباح
العربيه من القاهره